all
right
all right george what do you think turn
this microphone wait i gotta i gotta
make a point you will you could talk all
you want but i just no but i had
something to do with what kalila said
okay go ahead
i knew and you said it yourself when you
left
you said i forgot about it and i didn't
care about it anymore you said that
and i knew that that would be the case
and i says that's not enough
he this is important
and that's why i did what i did okay
mate george talk
did you feel good getting that go ahead
what do you think george well before the
podcast started you cut it cut ethan off
when i thought he was going to give me a
compliment so i really want to know what
that if that was going to be a
compliment before i answer but i think i
side with you bobby i think i'll never
get this compliment that i uh feel i
missed out on now i'm sorry turn this
mic off but i was just turning my camera
i don't know
that the mullet is looking good dude you
look healthy and good all right you know
what dude you're no no don't keep keep
his mic off all right
you're done you had your chance right i
want to say this right now how's the
mullet working for you
great i love it uh fans hate it but i
don't care oh the fans hate it really
it's fashionable now notice that it's
pretty hot
i want to move on
i want to move on from this okay so
thank you all right see the back
see what he's doing oh damn i've been
around you're right it's it's it's a wow
you look a jedi with this that's nuts
yeah that's good how long it takes to
grow that he knows how to occupy space
wow good for you good hair
nice my closing arguments is this my
closing argument is this okay
is if you also notice everyone in the
room and everyone listening right now
right ethan has squabble he's he's a pro
provocate
professor
provocateur that's not true right so he
has he had a show called frenemies with
yeah yeah right
fighting right i've seen him with oliver
tree fighting and
and he likes to call cause chaos and
mischief you know he's the chubby joker
yeah i mean that's what he is he's a
chubby joker and what you guys are is
buying into the chubby jokers i'll do it
again
i'm for the show you're the i'm the
yellow batman you're the one that
started that brought this public and
said ethan [ __ ] me over i was doing
this for you okay and then once you're
like yo ethan
was is a jewish piece of [ __ ] trickster
never said that and for the third that's
crazy i would never say that i i love
israel i i would never say that you
literally called me a jewish trickster
like five seconds into the show i called
you a tricky jew those are two different
things yeah yeah yeah yeah a jewish
stricture is restriction or something
else that's much worse that's with money
you're a chooky jew go ahead babe now
why did i have to eat the scab
oh it's good this is good i grabbed the
scab off of my neck right oh that's
because i said don't pick at it don't
pick it and it fell off it was a pretty
big scab
and i gave it to you and you i go eat
this and he goes i go you go i will do
anything but what is it and what what do
i get out of it yeah that's right right
and i go
nothing i'm driving you san diego that
was yesterday right and you go forget it
and then i put the [ __ ] scab in the
little compartment it's still in my car
get it oh so she didn't ever eat it oh
no
no but why did you say he was gonna
crash the car if he did because he
threatens he likes to play these like
games on our road trips but so you but
you didn't eat it
i didn't because there was no like
exchange of goods really
really so just can we just move on from
this just apologize and we can move on
it's bobby i just say i'm sorry for the
trick and then i'm it was
it wasn't a trick but i do apologize
okay that
you know it turned into a whole thing i
just love how he's like so sincere and
he's really just i love it you're really
good at what you do man
who you really are you're really good at
what you do and you're a professional
dude and it's like oh i'm sorry i
respect you i'm sorry that i scared you
and it turned out to be nothing okay all
right but like i'll tell you i'll be
honest with you
my mom
she's the type of person that will not
go to the doctor ever and she she almost
died because of this wait what did she
have she had like heart failure and she
was sitting in the house and
uh anyway she almost died she has a
pacemaker now and stuff but that's just
that didn't just happen once it happened
a bunch of times so
maybe that has something to do with it
that i'm like have someone close to me
like my mom who will like nearly die
before she
i mean up literally an ambulance came to
the house as she was dying of heart
failure and she was still saying no
don't take me to the hospital just i'll
just rough it out and they actually had
they were gonna they said okay fine but
you have to sign this form saying if you
die it's not our fault and then she's
like okay i'll go was that in l.a or in
israel that was in las vegas she lives
in las vegas they did they don't anymore
they live here oh good they live here
now is she okay now
yeah she's great now she has a pacemaker
so it helps her heart stay good but
but i care about you and i just wanted
to make sure you're okay it just looked
like a [ __ ] crazy-ass mold dude but
you're of dodging a question you got it
you got the results was it negative
i have cancer
anymore we don't know i don't i you
don't know yet we don't know yet it's
still coming back from the lab so maybe
we should wait for the results before
you get mad at me all right you know
what i'm not going to let this you know
what i know what you're doing right now
doing it and i'm not going to let it
enter my brain because no but literally
because how neurotic i am if it's
cancerous there to cut it off i already
i i'm the type of guy bro i walk around
if my knee i could find it out right now
actually if my knee hurts
oh my god i got scoliosis at the knee
you know i mean or if like i have a
headache i go i have a tumor cut out you
already cut it off i'm just saying i i'm
a neurotic kind of a guy and i obsess
about stuff like that because i don't
want to die
right you know i mean that's my biggest
today i couldn't sleep took a take a nap
today i was
you know i had a loot like a lucid nap
you know i mean where it was like it was
lucid mean susan means you're aware that
you're dreaming yeah so yeah and i was
like it was just all about death and i
couldn't sleep like was just like
like i always ask myself what is like
what do you see nothingness
right there's no awareness i mean it's
just that fear i don't know why i'm
because once it happens who gives a [ __ ]
i won't even know but it's like i don't
know why i worry about it okay here i
got the results what is it
hi mr lee i hope all is well good news
the biopsy showed a benign keratosis as
expected that's great no further
treatment necessary please see the
biopsy report i would say
when it's something that's serious
though you may want to get a second
opinion
[Laughter]
do you think so no no i'm just kidding i
don't want to [ __ ] with you i don't know
but do you think no honestly not because
there's no second opinion you removed it
they tested it it's negative world it's
great it's great okay good guys that's
great you know what and like i said look
you know what the good news is you're
gonna live you're fine you're right you
know what i don't have a positive at
least not there it might be somewhere
else on your body we don't know yet um
you know what
you know i'm going to take this as a
positive and as a you know what i'm
going to i'm going to
i'm going to give you the benefit of the
doubt and now listen i'm going to give
you the benefit that even though i have
all these reasons to believe that you're
a deceiver why would i trick you because
you tricked everyone else in life
yeah i mean that's i know your persona
and who you are like who who am i
tricking no i'm just saying you you're
like
you understand i've seen you with oliver
tree yeah i've seen you with trish trash
treasure chest
pilate
yeah yeah trisha talempo you know what i
mean right and i've seen the
combativeness you know i mean and that
kind of thing yeah and i know you do
that for entertainment right and on the
side you're a mellow guy this was
private it was a private thing okay then
you brought it public and then after
that you invited me on and i was like oh
here we go this is gonna be a whole
thing though
why didn't invite you on
i i asked i asked you yeah oh you did
i'll be honest with you i didn't even
know you were coming
really
that's kind of interesting no in general
i don't know who anyone's coming that's
true yes you do you knew a whole week
ago that ethan was